Justin Timberlake breaks his silence
after he was photographed holding hands
with another woman that's crazy the 38
year old singer who's been married to
Jessica Biel for seven years was snapped
on a balcony in New Orleans last month
holding hands with his palmer co-star
Alicia Wainwright the photos went viral
and on Wednesday Justin took to
Instagram to set the record straight
quote I displayed a strong lapse in
judgment but let me be clear nothing
happened between me and my co-star JT
went on to acknowledge that he drank way
too much that night and admitted that he
regrets his behavior this is not the
example I want to set for my son I
apologized to my amazing wife and family
for putting them through such an
embarrassing situation
my son is everything a source told et at
the time that Justin and Alicia's
interaction was totally innocent adding
that it was nothing more than a
gathering of friends cast and crew
members a second source said that JT and
30 year-old Alicia are like brother and
sister
and their hangout was quote harmless
Alicia's rep told ET quote there is no
validity to the speculation as for
Justin's relationship with his wife
Jessica a source tells ET that they're
committed to staying together quote -
even though Justin works and travels a
great deal and he is so much in the
public eye both Jessica and Justin are
wonderfully dedicated parents who both
have careers which can present some
challenges it's like that that once you
find that person that's like a baptism
where you're like I can't go back you
know that I mean like I don't I can't go
back so which is what fatherhood's like
to
[Music]